JUSTEB--ONFERENCE.WE'VSTN A TO
INRME JUST GOTTEN A N OF NEW
HAVEE FLAB T, OMOLE E , O,SSO
THREATENED TO CRASH TOO INTO AA
KIOUNDED UAS
HIS PLANINTO A FIELD, A LOT OF S
TION HOW OUTEAR DIRECTLY FROM PF
STING
TO ASS
ACCORDING PO
THHEPERSON ON BOARD, AY AB
NEGOTIATORS  P
POEGHE BROUGHT IN, ADING TO
R MOST
THIS PERSON NGHIS
BEECHC TO THAND HE
MAKINSU ADDED THE POWER IN AND
PERSIS P
AND THEN TE PLANE,THE MEF
FUELOU.M
TINDA
SOYBEA HEARD
WITNESSES IN, IS ARD THIST WITH
.
INTERESTING, SA THE BEST POSSIE
SCEN POSSIBLE OUT
OF THIS, NOBODY ON
BOARD SERIY  ON
THIOUSLY HURT.THPES
LANE WAS A LINEM AT TY
ANIR
ITD THNIGHT RE
KNEWOULD
RUOF
FUELCONTACVIA PHONE IN WHICHIN
LIWA TCISSENTI
OVER.
>> IINCREDIBLE,
E  T
AT NOWHARGED WH LARCENY AND MAN
ON TO ATS WELL.
TE IT.  ANY TIMPETE MUNTEAN,
BRONN WOODRUFF.CNN WTVA,
M SITTINOWN EEINYOU SO MUCH FO
LO PLANEHERE IE
RI ON THEI'PROXIMATELY EIT S T
THM.S. 4
ERHETHD T SIING
TSN.JUST AT THE SC
ERHENE
STERI THINY , WHEN I
SAY EVERYBODISF ,
E 7:00S MORNING,
SAWHIY FROM
THLOPARTMENT, ITTE.NOT TUPELOANA
BOOK SWATCH
PEOPLE WE E,
COULDEEAD OVE VE WTV OUR FACEB
Y PEOPLE.
LE  G
LIKE, NEI NEED TO TAKELTER.WHAT.
DON'T KNOW WHAT TO TELL YOU.
JUSTP  AND
EE SKY.
BUT RIGHT NOW EVERYBOD JUS
EAA SIGH O
>> Y PROVIDED A PUBLIC S
THTIEKW EXACTLY WHERE TH
ANU'OT O
SOMETIMES YOU ULTH
WG VE LOW
SO
OHE HOMES.K YOU ABOUT WHETHER .
EVERYBODTHE SPH AID, SIGH OF
G HERE LOOS HA WD THERE O INJUR.